y
[Música]
tanto el izquierdista gustavo petro como
el populista rodolfo hernández ya
ejercieron su derecho al voto en la
segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales colombianas
fernández se mantuvo en silencio ante la
prensa mientras que petro denunció
presuntos intentos sistemáticos por
anular votos y pidió a la ciudadanía
revisar con atención los tarjetones
en francia va concluyendo la jornada en
la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
legislativas y de nuevo con una cifra de
abstención que sería protagonista el
54% del electorado no habría acudido a
las urnas según proyecciones el
presidente emmanuel macrón quiere
defender su mayoría absoluta en el
legislativo frente a la alianza nubes de
izquierda
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
silencia y continúa su visita en el sur
del país y afirmó que no entregarán a
nadie esta región clave mientras tanto
las fuerzas rusas atacaron la ciudad de
jarque en las últimas horas quien
denuncia que moscú está reforzando su
ofensiva sobre esta urbe mientras que el
secretario general de la otan advierte
que la guerra puede extenderse por años
tenemos el reporte de ucrania
momento de actualizar las noticias en la
pantalla de france 24 gracias por
continuar con nosotros mi nombre es juan
pupiales
transcurren las primeras horas en
colombia de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales tanto rodolfo
hernández el populista como la
izquierdista gustavo petro ya votaron en
este día clave hernández lo hizo en
bucaramanga su bastión y no ofreció ni
una sola declaración a la prensa a petro
por su parte emitió su papeleta en
bogotá el antiguo alcalde de capitalinos
y compareció tras ejercer su derecho y
denunció un supuesto intento sistemático
y anular sufragios por lo que pidió a
sus seguidores prestar particular
atención a los tarjetones
en muchas zonas de alta votación por
nosotros
han entregado tarjetones previamente
marcados con un punto o alguna señal en
el voto en blanco un intento sistemático
de anular votos que irían por el cambio
por eso le pedimos a toda la ciudadanía
que revise el tarjetón antes de votar
para evitar que haya señales que puedan
anular su voto los veremos
en las horas de la tarde cuando el
pueblo colombiano nos designe como su
presidente gracias muy amantes
39 millones de personas están llamadas a
las urnas en esta jornada en el país y
quien también ya emitió su voto fue el
presidente iván duque quien hizo un
llamado a confiar en las instituciones y
respetar los resultados
y hoy tenemos que ir todos los
colombianos a las urnas sin miedos sin
intimidaciones sin prejuicios sin sesgos
a elegir al próximo presidente de la
república esto tiene que ser una fiesta
de la democracia con confianza en las
instituciones y con plena confianza en
el veredicto del pueblo colombiano
para conocer desde el terreno cómo
avanza esta jornada para colombia vamos
a conectar con nuestro periodista andrés
granadillo en bogotá desde donde
recibirá los resultados el candidato
gustavo petro andrés usted se encuentra
en una ciudad en donde petro obtuvo
cerca del 50 por ciento de los votos en
la primera vuelta cuál es el ambiente en
esta urbe
pues precisamente en este sitio donde
están habilitadas para votar 557.000
personas hay muchísima afluencia de
gente el gran bastión de gustavo petro
es precisamente aquí bogotá y estamos
con uno de sus seguidores que nos va a
hablar acerca de cómo ve usted la
jornada electoral pues bien lado
tranquila aquí en corferias y ésta
y viniendo la mente agotar
intranquilidad en paz lo que decían de
la protesta social yo no veo por ningún
lado muchos atrás está votando en paz
como debe ser cómo ve usted que gane el
presidente gustavo petro el presidente
del candidato gustavo petro y porque él
debe ganar las elecciones
pues yo quisiera que ganara gustavo
petro espero que sea república porque de
los dos proyectos de los proyectos y de
los dos planes del gobierno creo que es
el que más le conviene al país en estos
momentos
por lo que los cambios que expresa por
lo que hay en él en lo que está pasando
en colombia pues el cambio climático es
uno de los factores que toca tener muy
en cuenta para para que no sólo colombia
sino el mundo entero entero pueda
sobrevivir hay una línea que no debemos
pasar y estamos próximos a pasar en
cambio climático y sexualidad y no se
puede que no puede pasar como usted si
gana el candidato el ingeniero rodolfo
hernández
pues yo he leído el promedio hubiera me
realmente no lo es no me convence el
promedio gobierno mucho de lo que dice
el
doctor el señor candidato rode fernández
son cosas que pidió tienen para poder
congreso y no creo que sea no creo que
lo pueda hacer así como como él dice que
voy a acabar en el apoyo el próximo el
primer decreto que va a lanzar ese es el
como él
que reducir el congreso y bajar los
sueldos a los congresistas no pase
porque por separación de poderes quien
se podría bajar los salarios serían
ellos mismos en el circuito seriamente
no creo que así como está la mente mente
no puede hacer muchas gracias pues
seguiremos en esta jornada electoral las
mesas las mesas de votación cierran a
las 4 de la tarde es muy posible que a
partir de las 5 de la tarde ya
conozcamos quién será el próximo
presidente de colombia así esta
estimación es de la registraduría de
colombia y precisamente de colombianos
vamos a francia porque quedan pocas
horas para que se cierren las urnas en
la segunda vuelta de los comicios
legislativos en el país se renuevan los
577 diputados de la asamblea nacional
según la proyección de ipsos sobre este
área para france24 la abstención será de
un 54 por ciento superior al 52 5 por
ciento de la primera vuelta que fue la
mayor abstención en estos comicios en la
quinta república este proceso se muestra
clave para el presidente emmanuel macrón
quien viene de ser reelegido y que
quiere mantener su mayoría absoluta en
el legislativo de cara a sacar adelante
reformas como el aumento de la edad de
jubilación en frente tiene a la alianza
de izquierda y ecologistas nubes que
buscan ser la principal fuerza de
oposición escuchamos algunos electores
voto en blanco porque para mí los
candidatos se postulan para el puesto
para juegos de poder más que para servir
realmente a la gente
hace una semana teníamos una pequeña
cola esperando con impaciencia que
abriera la oficina una decena de
personas hoy sólo tenemos unas diez
personas después de un periodo de tiempo
un poco más largo desafortunadamente
tenemos la sensación de que este día
será menos participativo que la semana
anterior pero mantenemos la esperanza
vamos a ucrania porque las autoridades
rusas están lanzando una nueva ofensiva
contra la ciudad de jarquín según
denuncia ucrania esta urbe del este del
territorio de la segunda más grande del
país registró hoy el ataque sobre una
planta de reparación de tanques que
contaba con artillería entregada por
aliados extranjeros las autoridades
ucranianas advierten que la situación se
complica en la zona con la retoma de
territorios por parte de las fuerzas
rusas sobre el terreno en kharkiv se
encuentra nuestra enviada especial y en
ese avión quien previamente nos entregó
más detalles
esta es una de las más de mil escuelas
que han sido dañadas desde el comienzo
de este conflicto este es un edificio de
tres plantas no queda nada en pie como
pueden ver el panorama es desolador las
paredes están completamente estropeadas
hay restos del techo que están a punto
de caerse bancos que han quedado
completamente calcinado también cables
sueltos restos de libros hardcore la
ciudad en la que nos encontramos sigue
siendo una de las localidades más
afectadas de este conflicto de hecho en
las últimas horas las autoridades
ucranianas han informado que las tropas
rusas han lanzado una nueva ofensiva
sobre esta ciudad que recordemos es la
segunda localidad más importante de
ucrania y ya había sido asediada al
comienzo de este conflicto esto también
refleja que la guerra en ucrania está
lejos de apagarse lo ha dicho también
hoy el secretario general de la otan
quien ha afirmado que este conflicto
podría durar años por su parte el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
se encuentra de visitas de fin de semana
en el sur del país y afirmó que no
llevan a entregar esta región clave que
da acceso al mar negro a nadie estas
fueron las palabras del mandatario
visite nuestra posición de primera línea
en la región de micro life y también la
región de desa hable con nuestros
defensores militares policías guardia
nacional defensa territorial su estado
de ánimo es confiado y mirándolos a los
ojos es obvio que todos ellos me dudan
de nuestra victoria les agradecí por el
servicio por la protección de nuestro
estado agradecía a los padres de niños
tan valientes presenté premios a los
mejores presenté la orden de la estrella
dorada al héroe de ucrania al coronel
vadim y jarecki comandante de la brigada
59 de infantería motorizada separada no
regalaremos el sur a nadie le volveremos
todo eso es nuestro y el mar será
ucraniano y seguro
su carrera y seguimos hablando de la
guerra en ucrania porque este domingo
llegó a este país el representante de la
unión europea para los derechos humanos
y mont dio amor el alto funcionario
visitó las localidades de busca en donde
se encontraron fosas comunes de civiles
al comienzo de este conflicto y también
estuvo en irvine otro suburbio de kiev
la capital en donde se han registrado
también otras violaciones al derecho
internacional
gilmore busca así reforzar el apoyo del
organismo comunitario a ucrania
y hablamos no sólo de quienes cometieron
los crímenes los crímenes directamente
en el lugar por supuesto que tienen
responsabilidad pero también estamos
hablando de quienes están en la cadena
de mando si es necesario hasta el de muy
arriba
es por eso tiene que percibirse mediante
la investigación de quienes lo están
llevando a cabo se despide en rastree
keys john autor suerte regueral en el
sur de asia el monzón ha provocado
importantes inundaciones y un elevado
número de víctimas según las autoridades
al menos 42 personas han muerto en india
y bangladesh como consecuencia de las
lluvias las inundaciones y los deslaves
millones de personas quedaron
abandonadas o sin hogar
las calles se han convertido en ríos en
esta ciudad de bangladesh los residentes
luchan para moverse ya que el agua les
llega a la cintura mientras que sus
casas quedaron completamente inundadas
durante varios días las lluvias
torrenciales e incesantes han estado
azotando el noreste de bangladesh el
ejército ha llegado para evacuar a los
más aislados por las inundaciones según
las autoridades más de 4 millones de
personas están atrapadas algunos
intentan huir por sí mismos arriesgando
sus vidas más al sur en la ciudad
portuaria de chittagong varios
residentes han muerto por los
deslizamientos de tierra
las fuertes lluvias también están
afectando a la vecina india en el estado
de assam el río brahmaputra uno de los
más grandes de asia han desbordado sus
diques inundando 3.000 pueblos los
servicios de emergencia están al máximo
de su capacidad
hemos rescatado y evacuado a casi 150
personas y traeremos de vuelta a otras
50 que están actualmente igualadas
en esta región el monzón provoca
regularmente inundaciones pero según los
expertos el cambio climático está
aumentando su gravedad y frecuencia
esto es la tercera vez que nos
enfrentamos a las inundaciones
esta vez la inundación ha sumergido
completamente las calles todo lo que se
reparó después de la segunda inundación
está nuevamente en ruinas
la situación sólo puede empeorar ya que
se esperan fuertes lluvias en los
próximos dos días
vamos a túnez porque nuevamente cientos
de personas salieron a las calles para
protestar contra los planes de un
referéndum constitucional impulsado por
el presidente karzai & la manifestación
fue organizada por el llamado frente
para la salvación una coalición que
incluye al partido islamista moderado
ennahda el más grande de un parlamento
que fue disuelto por el propio estalle
el pasado mes de marzo el país también
estado marcado por varias semanas de
movilizaciones de los jueces tras el
despido de 57 magistrados también por
decisión de xajay
hoy estamos retrocediendo hoy el estado
es incapaz de atender la más mínima de
las demandas el estado está en
bancarrota y no puede proporcionar lo
mínimo o lo necesario para el pueblo el
estado está dispuesto a levantar los
subsidios a costa de la clase media y
empobrecida no hay soluciones ni
perspectivas para esta gente pobre y
desposeída hoy sentimos que caixa jet no
tiene ninguna identidad en el país y
túnez no tiene futuro con caixa jet
y
terminamos así esta emisión informativa
france24 quédense en nuestra pantalla
porque aquí tendremos un cubrimiento
especial de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones legislativas de francia y
también de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales en colombia la
información continua en nuestra pantalla
y también en france24 punto com
[Música]